Russian forces have withdrawn from what
remains of this part The Village
people have fled
I destroyed Ukrainian military vehicle
is towed from the battlefield
dead Russian soldiers in the grass
the Ukrainian military last week
announced it had completely retaken the
village of stories
but that's not quite true
the crater you can see here is as a
result of a Russian airstrike
yesterday the Ukrainian military are
telling us that although they've cleared
so they say the majority of this Village
there is still ongoing fighting on the
outskirts and they say they are facing
Fierce resistance from Russian forces
Ukraine's counter-offensive was expected
for months and that gave Russian forces
time to prepare
they have strong air power and a lot of
infantry supported by Heavy Artillery
they're moving slowly towards us but
we're killing them we're conducting
small offensive operations on the
outskirts of the village along the
Forest Lane but there are many mines
around 200 kilometers North near the
Russian occupied town of cremina barrage
after barrage of artillery fire Echoes
through the forests
Ukrainian soldiers here are nervous
Russian positions are a few hundred
meters away
Ukrainian forces retook this area during
a counter-offensive last summer neither
side has made a major advance for months
but as the Ukrainian Army began to probe
for weakness in Russian defenses to the
south things here began to change
honestly there is nothing good here
visitation is very tense
the trench Commander tells us to take
cover because Russian helicopter
gunships are in the area
there is constant fire from mortars
artillery helicopters airstrikes and
Small Arms their sort our position in
small groups they are trying to break
through to capture an important Supply
route
hard graft and early days says Ukraine
and its NATO backers
if there ever is a decisive breakthrough
it could take months Channel staff at Al
Jazeera eastern Ukraine